So for more than a year now, really, since
Donald Trump's 2016 election, I've been saying,
and others have been saying,
uh, that Donald Trump is a symptom of the
problem, but Trump is not the problem in and
of itself.
So as an example, to start thinking about
this, Donald Trump didn't create anti intellectual
aneurysm and pseudo intellectual wisdom, but
he invigorated it.
He benefited from the fact that pseudo and
anti intellectual Islam has been growing in
the United States for decades.
And he actually continues to maintain this
core and sort of immutable base of support,
uh, at least in part because of the anti in
pseudo intellectual ism that pervades that
base.
Another example, Donald Trump didn't create
extremism, although he certainly has fomented
it.
But what he did do was coalesce the extremism,
allow the extremist to feel more emboldened
in comfortable, uh, in the public eye more
so than they have in a very long time.
And there's a really nice piece in the Guardian
that I read yesterday by British journalist
Gary Young, who by the way, if you've not
heard of him, Google or even search on Youtube,
Gary Young, Richard Spencer, uh, and you'll
see some pretty interesting conversations
between young and a white nationalist.
Richard Spencer and Gary Young really spells
this out in this guardian piece and it's a
much broader picture.
Even then, young paints a, a young says, forget
about the rise of Trump for a second.
If you are shocked by the global rise of the
right, then you weren't paying attention.
And he's exactly right.
And what this means is that Trump, uh, but
Brexit, Modi winning reelection in India,
the nationalist anti immigration parties in
multiple European countries, this is something
that we were seeing the sort of precursors
to for quite some time and young points out
that if you look at the people who are doing
the voting in those countries, of course they
were eventually going to have an impact.
These are Gary Young's words from the article
quote.
I'd like to focus on one thing that unites
them.
The, the countries which keeps producing these
shocks are every bit is racist, xenophobic,
and discriminatory as their voting habits
suggest.
This is not some new virus.
It's a susceptibility to a chronic illness
that is crippled us for years.
These electoral victories are largely but
not exclusively the products of those age
old prejudices.
Not because everyone who voted for them was
racist, but because all racists who did go
to the polls voted for them.
The intensity of that racism is now growing
as the victors use their podiums and despatch
boxes to amplify their voice, their bigotry,
giving confidence and license for people to
spread the they're poison.
This is not shocking and there's a lot of
blame to go around.
We're partially to blame for it.
Okay?
Obama was elected and too many people said,
we've solved something.
Something big could have been racism, could
have been whatever.
But the problems continued and Obama was very
limited in what he was able to do.
He was also limited in, in some senses by
what he tried to do.
Uh, and in the end there was republican obstruction.
The right wing went crazy very successfully.
Ginning up all sorts of racial and ethnic,
uh, animus.
And then in comes Donald Trump and all of
these horrible, disgusting enclaves that we're
invigorated against, Barack Obama are now
feeling vindicated and empowered and emboldened.
And we're seeing the effect of that.
We're seeing the effect of that in terms of
the victories of these white nationalists,
uh, uh, and more generally nationalists, xenophobic,
anti-immigration parties in Europe.
Uh, we're seeing it in the emboldening and
increase in hate crimes and antisemitism and
all the rest of it in the United States.
Uh, and that's one piece of it.
The Democratic Party is definitely to blame
in the United States.
Obama won in 2008 and then the democratic
establishment or much of it takes this attitude
of let's compromise on stuff with Republicans
because we're bigger than they are and we're
better than them and you know what we are
to a degree, but they weren't going to compromise
on a lot of the things that the Democratic
Party thought or tried to compromise on.
And meanwhile the Democratic Party, while
failing to actually get a bunch of stuff done
because of this bogus idea of compromising
with republicans, maintained the pro corporate
status quo in a lot of other areas while having
this massive angry movement go growing against
them under Barack Obama.
And then here we are with Donald Trump, not
as the problem, but as the sort of in a sense,
logical end result of the circumstances that
were fomented in part by the Democratic Party
under Barack Obama.
And of course the majority of the blame goes
to the extremists.
Like I want to be really clear about that.
I don't do this both sides stuff on the show
when there is a both sides thing, I'll still
say that even though there is some blame on
both sides, here's where the majority of the
blame is.
You know, we could talk about the left under
Obama, we can talk about the Democratic Party.
The majority of the blame is the extremist
since they are the ones that we are actually
fighting against here.
So in any case, we should be disgusted by
the rise of the extremist xenophobic.
Right.
We should be angry.
We should be activated and we should be doing
things to push back the supplies in Europe.
This certainly applies in the United States
when it comes to the upcoming 2020 election.
But being surprised is the last thing we should
be.
And what's really important.
I mean, listen, we got to get Trump out.
Okay?
There's no question about that.
But when we think about the future of Homo
sapiens in the modern world of nation states
and governments and all of this other stuff
that makes up today status quo, we shouldn't
overstate Trump as being the problem, but
rather a sort of predictable, predictable,
and logical end result of decades of anti
intellectual ism and ginning up these, uh,
sort of visceral responses with the Republican
conservative red meat.
We should think about it as a symptom of the
problem that we want to solve rather than
the problem itself.
Really good piece by Gary Young, which I encourage
you
to read.